and welcoming back to the program today
Cory Dogen who's professor of sociology
at Stone Hill College also author of the
book kill it to save it recently
available in paperback Corey last time
you were on we talked a lot about well
many different things including the idea
of the privatization of different areas
of government under the pretense of
saving some of those institutions and
recently we've had this sort of come up
again when thinking about the VA and the
fired VA secretary saying that part of
the reason that he was pushed out was
his lack of desire to go in the
privatization direction which the Trump
administration seemed to want we've seen
Trump be critical of the united states
postal service another favorite of the
right to talk about privatization what
do you think is really the catalyst for
this desire to privatize is it the
possibility of privatizing in a way that
does crony capitalist handouts or is it
sort of the moral idea of private is
better than public yeah well that's a
great question and a great way to frame
it because I would argue as I do in the
book that it's both and what what the
book really tries to explain is how the
what I consider killa to save it
mentality and framework for American
policymaking today is in fact crony
capitalism with the kind of added
ideological and cultural component that
it tries to convince people that it's
actually better for them and so on the
one hand the privatization of the public
sector is this attempt to just wrench
out whatever profit is still possible
from the public sector privatizing
everything that works and everything
that doesn't work for the sake of
handouts to corporate capital but at the
same time justifying them through this
kind of morality play about hard work
who's deserving the corporate sector
knows better than the public sector how
to run things and that ideology is still
strong despite decades and decades of
fail
on the part of the private sector to run
public institution yeah it's amazing how
successful the talking point has been of
government is inefficient and I'd rather
things be handled by the private sector
as if it's some it's almost like a
dogmatic religious type belief when the
person is usually more nuanced right
like for example my my economic views
are most closely aligned with like the
well regulated social democracies of
Scandinavia which recognize that hey
capitalism for many areas does create
incentives for creativity and research
and development and innovation but not
in all areas do we want that market
system health care for example being one
of them education be one of them the
simple idea that private is always
better than public that government is
always inefficient even by some on the
left has been accepted to some degree
and I find that very well that's right
no I agree and you know I think that in
the past you know you and I probably
could have had an interesting
conversation where we might actually
disagree on whether or not the public
sector could inspire that level of
creativity and whether or not capitalism
was necessary at all but that kind of
conversation between people on the left
and the further left has been so drowned
out by the rightward movement of our
politics that it was you know and and
and I blame Clinton as much as Reagan
for this that the idea of triangulation
strategies on the part of the Democrats
was such that they bought into that
ideology that the private sector
actually could run things better and
that the public sector needed to be
downsized and instead of improving and
and and trying to create a bureaucracy
that worked
the mantra became killed a bureaucracy
and so by killing the bureaucracy it
became a kind of ruse for the right
under which it privatization became the
narrative and as you suggest it's become
the narrative to such a degree that even
most Democrats can't run on trying
to recreate a public sector as the book
suggests we were actually moving in the
direction of many of the social welfare
democracies the welfare state of Western
Europe up until the 1960s and 1970s and
it was really the post-vietnam era and
eventually Reagan that saw us take this
great you turn away from a public sector
and a welfare state and towards what we
have now which is just in some ways the
the worst kind of you know banditry
capitalism yeah and we've even seen how
it has tricked or bamboozled or
convinced a lot of right-wing voters as
we've been talking about I mean at
minimum dating back to the 2010
successes of the tea party but certainly
well beyond into supporting candidates
who are straight up running on policies
that wouldn't be good for those voters
and and you know tax plans are an
example and you say well hold on a
second this tax plan wouldn't benefit
you it would benefit the very rich and
there's sort of this idea that well I
might be in that group someday as
statistically and unlikely as it is I
think it's similar with some of these
public institutions right which is
listen you'd benefit now from more
public health funding from whatever the
case may be and it's sort of the same
reaction like yeah well that may be in
the short term but the truth is that the
private sector is just more efficient
and I'd rather than run it it's an
amazing bamboozling of voters that's
happened I think that's true to an
extent and and the one thing I would I
would add as a caveat is that I think
we've seen in part with Donald Trump's
election although I think it's really
hard to take out the hardcore kind of
white supremacy that that really shape
shaped a lot of his his voting base but
regardless I think we also have to look
at the ways in which it may not simply
be a bamboozling of a of an electorate
that just was too easily swayed by by
falsehoods and by lies and and Bakke
news but it's also that they've tapped
in to this morality as you suggest and I
argue in the book that that morality
goes back to our
very beginnings as a nation that this
mythology about hyper individualism
about rugged burly guys it only let free
from public regulations and
responsibilities will succeed and that
that's what's always driven our country
to its great success is just mythology
but it's still deeply ingrained in our
core values and identity so so while I
do agree that there's a certain
bamboozling going on a lot of the
bamboozling is so hardwired into our
into our mythology and our identity that
it's very easily tapped by these
right-wing spin doctors and I think
maybe that's why the populist rhetoric
that we heard from both Bernie Sanders
and Donald Trump that's right it worked
in a sense even though there's of course
a very big difference between left-wing
and right-wing populism and there's a
night and day difference in terms of
what the legislative actions would have
been by someone like Bernie Sanders and
the more authoritarian actions that
we've seen under Donald Trump but I
think that if we go back and saw and
sort of considered how powerful the
populist sounding rhetoric was to both
voters that called themselves left and
right I think that's kind of a big
indication of the predisposition from
from people to be attracted so those
ideas given what we've seen in terms of
neoliberalism and corporatism for the
last 50 or more years would you say oh
absolutely and and you know as I say in
the book you know populism cuts both
ways and you know for me the weakness
and and the weakness of vision as well
as will of the Democrats really played
through in this election and so you know
that this was a moment where the kind of
left populism that Sanders represented
was right and I think right for for
winning an election and the idea that
that Clinton was the selection in part
because of a lot of really bad you know
institutionalized party politics and
power from the Democratic Party but also
the notion that Sanders wasn't electable
which you know leads us to the question
of you know could he have been any less
electable than Clinton so you know
the Democratic Party was was holdin to
its own set of neoliberalism and I think
was scared by the kind of left wing
populism that Sanders represented we'll
see whether the Democrats in 2020 2018
and then 2020 can welcome a much more
radical left vision the kind of public
welfare social welfare politics that you
were discussing earlier or they're gonna
remain these kinds of you know so-called
centrist Democrats who are afraid of
real change are you so I think there's
there's certainly more than two views on
this but two views about how Democrats
should run in 2018 and in 2020 would be
on the one hand those who say you need
to just run as far to the left as
possible as far to the left as the
Democratic Party will sort of allow
candidates to run and allow them to win
primaries and that unbalanced you're
going to do better that way there's
another approach which I find to be a
little more pragmatic and I think it's
it's maybe a little more thoughtful
which is you need to calculate what type
of candidate will do best depending on
where they're running so if you're
running against a corporate Democrat in
West Virginia versus against a
Republican in Texas versus who knows
someone in Vermont that there's sort of
different types of candidates and
approaches that make sense
do you subscribe more to one or the
other view or some third view I haven't
mentioned yeah I'm a big fan of third
views I would suggest that you know
there's there's a truth to both but
ultimately you know especially in
congressional elections at statewide
elections you know I'm a grassroots
organizer at heart and and and a
Democrat with a small D you know and a
socialist I guess with a big s but I
would suggest that you know the people
will have to decide this and too often
we leave it the party strategists and
party functionaries and one of the
things that came out of the last failed
election in 2016 we're all of these
memos from places in
Pennsylvania and Michigan and Wisconsin
from you know union workers and and and
other kind of local leaders who are
saying you know the Democrats you know
never took on the class argument and
they never took on the opportunity to
talk about a multicultural working class
as opposed to a much more focused
identity politics that seemed more for
marketing purposes than they did for you
know social change purposes I really
think the grassroots decide this in in
ways that are really important and so
you know I would suggest that that the
grassroots really is further to the left
among the Democrats they tend to isolate
them after elections they love them when
they're doing the organizing work and
they're the ones that eventually have to
determine what the ideology of the party
is going to be I think it's a much
further left ideology than the Democrats
who hold the power of the party are
probably willing to accept so I think
we'll see the Democrats do better I
think we'll see the Democrats be very
schizophrenic in many ways and so you'll
see the kinds of conservative Democrats
like more like Jones in Alabama and and
and some of the recent congressional
election special elections but I also
think we'll see some some really great
left candidates winning as well and I
think there's gonna be a little bit of a
you know not quite a civil war but
certainly a real power struggle in the
party come 2020 the book now available
in paperback is kill it to save it we've
been speaking with the book's author and
professor of sociology at Stone Hill
College kori Duggan kori great to talk
to you again great to talk to you David
thank you so much